R
GRIFFIN GRIFFIN LIVE FROM THE
PENTAGON.
THANK YOU.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CAN'T
GET ITS MESSAGING ALL SORTED OUT
DIFFERENT PLACES ON POTENTIAL
THEY NEW TERROR THREATS
ESPECIALLY COMING OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
>> THE CONTRADICTIONS OVER THE
PAST FEW DAYS RAISING RED FLAGS
FOR LAWMAKERS.
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT PETER
DOOCY HAS THAT PART OF THE STORY
TONIGHT.
>> THE STORY KEEPS CHANGING.
>> ARE THERE AL-QAEDA MEMBERS
AND REMNANTS IN AFGHANISTAN?
YES.
>> BUT TWO DAYS EARLIER THE
PRESIDENT SAID THE OPPOSITE.
>> LOOK, LET'S PUT THIS THING IN
PERSPECTIVE HERE.
WHAT INTEREST DO WE HAVE IN
AFGHANISTAN AT THIS POINT WITH
AL-QAEDA GONE?
>> THE CONFUSION IS CONCERNING
FOR CRITICS.
>> I'M ABSOLUTELY CONCERNED
ABOUT IT.
CLEARLY HE IS EITHER SENILE OR
JUST IN DENIAL ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON.
>> THE NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER
CLAIMS THERE'S NOTHING TO SEE
HERE.
>> ARE YOU PRESENTING THE
PRESIDENT WITH THE FULL PICTURE
OR IS HE JUST MISAPPLYING THE
INTELLIGENCE WHEN HE MAKES THESE
PUBLIC STATEMENTS?
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS REFERRING
TO AL-QAEDA'S CAPABILITY TO
ATTACK THE UNITED STATES, WHICH
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY TELLS
US TODAY IS NOT PRESENT IN
AFGHANISTAN.
>> BIDEN OFFICIALS CITE SECURITY
RISK AS THE REASON THEY WON'T
EXPLAIN HOW THEY PLAN TO
EVACUATE AMERICANS WHO CAN'T GET
TO THE KABUL AIRPORT.
>> I GUESS YOU CAN PRAY OUT
DIFFERENT SCENARIO NARROWS HOW
WE COULD HAVE WITHDRAWN FROM
AVERAGE.
I'M PRETTY CONFIDENT NONE OF
THEM COULD BE WORSE THAN WHAT
JOE BIDEN DID WITH THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS STUCK BEHIND TALIBAN
LINES.
>> WORDS MATTER AND THERE IS ONE
THIS WHITE HOUSE DOESN'T IN THE
HEADLINES ABOUT THE AFGHANISTAN
DRAWDOWN.
>> DOES THE PRESIDENT HAVE A
SENSE THAT MOST OF THE CRITICISM
IS NOT OF LEADING AFGHANISTAN,
IT'S THE WAY THAT HE HAS ORDERED
IT TO HAPPEN?
BY PULLING THE TROOPS BEFORE
GETTING THESE AMERICANS WHO ARE
NOW STRANDED?
DOES HE HAVE A SENSE OF THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I THINK IT'S
IRRESPONSIBLE TO SAY AMERICANS
ARE STRANDED THERE ARE NOT.
>> THERE ARE NO AMERICANS
STRANDED IS THE WHITE HOUSE'S
OFFICIAL POSITION ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN AFGHANISTAN?
>> I'M JUST CALLING YOU OUT FOR
SAYING THAT WE'RE STRANDING
AMERICANS IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> SHE ARGUES NONE OF THESE
AMERICANS WHO ARE SHELTERING IN
PLACE, HIDING FROM ISIS ARE
STRANDED BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
GETTING TEXTS AND EMAILS FROM
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD TWO ON COME
ARE A EVENTS TODAY.
ONE ABOUT COVID, ONE
CELEBRATING.
WBNA CHAMPION SEATTLE STORM NOT
ONE WORD ABOUT AFGHANISTAN.
BRET?
BRET: PETER, THE TEXTS AND
EMAILS DON'T COME WITH AN
ARMORED VEHICLE TO GET THEM TO
THE AIRPORT.
>> RIGHT.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, BEFORE
MANY JEN PSAKI SPOKANE JEN PSAKI
WAS SAYING THERE IS A SERIOUS
THREAT FROM ISIS AT THE AIRPORT.
AMERICANS WHO CANNOT BE BUT THEY
ARE N